one of the other knocks on Trump is that
on the point of populism is that he's a
demagogue oh Trump is just a total
demagogue he goes around he'll Pander to
anybody what we've seen over the years
is that really isn't true you could you
could attack Trump for all sorts of
different reasons but you can't really
attack him for being a demagogue because
demagogues are people who just tell the
audience whatever the audience wants to
hear they change their tune with every
single campaign appearance
Trump famously infamously doesn't do
that Trump is like a broken record he
never stops going on about the things
that he goes on about this has been one
of the criticisms of his campaign is he
won't shut up about the 2020 election
even though it might hurt him in the
polls well yeah maybe it'll hurt him in
the polls maybe it won't but he just
keeps talking about it he's stuck to his
same issues again and again and again
much more so than other candidates who I
think can can more rightly be accused of
demagoguery someone like Chris Christie
could much more rightly be accused of
demagoguery than somebody such as Donald
Trump